俺のスマホどこ行ったスマホの方 ok
ん
アート別だ皆さん牛乳知っていますでしょうか
知らない人はいないと思うけどなんだこれですがもう10人の6つ入ったら僕はいつも
これを飲んではおいしい牛乳は簡単に言えば大資産の設置から取れる
お乳ですを膣射いようがないよすごいことを見つけたんですよ
牛乳を100回100回振った牛乳は何もしてない順に比べて阿南と旨みの値が高く
なる傾向があるという証左結果が出ているみたいで本当のと頭が読んだかどうかじゃ
ないんですけどもそういう結果が出てるんで流入が真っ白なのは脂肪やタンパク質の
分子が小さな集団
作りコロイドという状態で用意下にあるためらしいですホロイドっていうものが均一に
広がっていると牛乳ってのはおいしくなるとこの紙バッグの中の牛乳も増えては均一な
状態で入れられているらしいです
がちだし脂肪の分子は脂肪の物資年サンバフェスの分社タンパク質の分子同士で集まり
やすくなるみたいそういう性質があるために冷蔵庫に静かにおいている
データに黒いの分布に偏りが出てきたら最初は均一に入ってた子犬なんだけどもおいて
グッズにねその中徐々に起因つじゃなくなってくるらしいです
なるほどながらこんな彼の心得が今均一じゃない理由近っじゃないんだけどもうこれは
振ってぐっとおいしくなるらしいですよ英語なんだ
まじか普通に驚きけど味が微妙に本当に違うらしいすごい
微妙な告げらしいんでずっと牛乳と降ってない件 new なぜの美味しさがばせる人
は味の違いが解る素晴らしい一になるみたいです
俺の出番だそこどうれ以外にアズの違いがわかる男なんていないだろ今日の動画では
売った牛乳と降ってない牛乳の味の違いを俺が当てるだけの調達明海天才的な動画で今
食ってないからとか頼っている状態でしょおいしくない方おいしくない方をこっちにし
ますまあ動かせないようにいる
その間は風た牛乳がお
そのペットボトル理想とされています
ok フルートおいしくなんだよね100回いるのかブーン
いいよな対象となって何か言ったっけあああああ
じゃあこんなげったんだから汗の違いはあるでしょうやたもう会わず黙って泡になっ
てるよこれうまいのかあまちゃんもう
rr future 触れちゃまずいのでパスこっちがうまいのでもあるこっちが
まずい中にこっちが美味しい十分です未だ見かけしして当てるんですけどもその辺
ちょっと入って味の違いだけどちょっとを感じさせてくれたじゃあ前方からうん
おいしい牛乳ただこっちのかどれくらい美味しいかったですね
ここでも徹底美味しくしてきますいただけます
わーかっ俺は完了わかるわかるわーぬーんっ
はいでは美味しいほぉやってみましょう
まずはこっちからいやまぁも選び便だよこれ本当に行けるからグイッといきます
ええええええ
me
ぐいっといきます
これさー
こっちが美味しい
こっちが100回2方
同じじゃねーか
war
ます
ちょっと俺には分からなかったな
けどなんか本当に年か科学的に違うみたいなのでもし良かったらみなさんやってみて
ください
僕は
味音痴です